if you're angrier about my tweet
regarding yesterday's shooting in
Nashville Tennessee then you are about
the fact that six people including three
kids are now dead as a result of that
shooting then we have a real problem
here I support people who pray if they
want to pray praying if that's important
to them but it doesn't prevent shootings
and so when elected officials offer
nothing more than thoughts and prayers
and then we have another shooting and
another one and another one and they
continue to offer nothing more than
thoughts and prayers they were the
target of my ire not the victims of the
shooting and that I stand by 100 anyone
who knows me knows I would never blame
the victims of a mass shooting for that
mass shooting thoughts and prayers are
fine but we have to go beyond it